les chômeurs ne désarme pas l'évacuation
des assedic maintenant ce sont d'autres
occupations à metz à guingamp à lyon et
à nantes
lionel jospin justifie sa politique de
fermeté 160 kilos de cocaïne répartis
dans les quatre roues d'une voiture la
plus grosse saisie de drogue à l'entrée
dû tunnel sous la manche
jacques chirac recevra mardi prochain
des maires pour évoquer la violence
urbaine portraits croisés dans ce
journal de deux nuls à dammarie-les-lys
autres avec messieurs ya cent ans le
journal l'aurore publiait à la une le
j'accuse de zola
il s'agit de l'acte le plus
révolutionnaire du siècle selon jean
jaurès
et puis du cinéma avec la sortie en
france de lolita d'après le
chef-d'oeuvre de nabokov l'amérique
puritaine refuse de distribuer le film
magistralement interprété par jeremy
eyes et la jeune dominique semaine
madame monsieur bonsoir la semaine qui
s'annonce sera marquée l'évidence par le
mouvement des chômeurs qui rebondit
après les évacuations d'hier avant la
manifestation nationale de mardi
les occupations ont repris ici ou là
dans d'autres locaux sous d'autres
formes
a nantes le maire jean marc ayrault
président du groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée demande à la justice
l'expulsion de chômeurs qui occupe le
centre communal d'action sociale
reportage jacques devaux gabriel camilla
ils occupent les locaux depuis le 2
janvier
ils sont une cinquantaine de chômeurs
parfois plus objet des assemblées
générales
aux dires des occupants l'activité du
centre communal d'action sociale n'a
jamais été entravée pourtant jean marc
ayrault le maire socialiste de nantes a
demandé à la justice de faire évacuer
les lieux
c'est complètement contradictoire
comportement
surtout dans une mairie dont on dit
perpétuellement confetto pour le social
j'ai vu le ministre des transports à la
télévision dire que le dialogue était
ouvert et qu'il fallait le continuer
vous trouvez ça un dialogue de se faire
expulser par les forces de l'ordre
un dimanche moi je pense pas une
décision qui n'a pas choqué que les
chômeurs les élus écologistes de nantes
ont condamné la démarche du maire on ne
peut pas à la fois reconnaître une
certaine représentativité expulsé deux
jours après il faut ne pas avoir peur
des mouvements qui se crée aujourd'hui
parce que ce sont des mouvements qui se
créent à gauche qu'il faut savoir
dialoguer au sein de cette gauche selon
la gauche plurielle la puissance pour
les chômeurs en tout cas le milliard
accordés et bien mais trop peu pour
arrêter un mouvement et ils le font
savoir une vie depuis des années qui
vont créer des emplois mais ya pas de
boulot c'est clair il y en a pas ils
vont pas nous mentir que longtemps que
ça ne va pas du tout alors au moins
qu'ils aient le courage de nous faire
vivre correctement
le tribunal de nantes a décidé
l'évacuation des lieux
ce soir les chômeurs à temps
d'intervention des forces de l'ordre
mais ce ne sera pas leur chant du cygne
ils poursuivront le mouvement sous
d'autres formes ajoutant que la mairie
n'a pas souhaité communiquer
immédiatement elle le fera dans la
soirée sans doute alors que les
réactions politiques parfois dissonante
au sein de la majorité plurielle se
multiplient après l'évacuation par la
force des assedic lionel jospin dans son
fiel de cintegabelle justifie sa
politique de fermeté
il faut une autorité républicaine nous
l'écoutons quand on est amené à prendre
des décisions importantes
quant à la fois
dialogue avec des représentants des
chômeurs quand même temps on dégage un
effort financier important pour les
situations d'urgence répu difficile même
si c'est par la hauteur l'ensemble
pourrait être du chômage
dans le même moment on dit parce qu'il
faut à la fois la justice le dialogue
mais aussi dans cette société un peu une
parole d'autorité que après trois
semaines un mois d'occupation de lieux
qui sont les lieux où les chômeurs
inscrits au chômage ou toujours
indemnités on peut par l'occupation peut
pas être une forme permanente de
revendications une forme de
revendications et de livres et qu'on dit
donc il faut pas ça reste ainsi je pense
que dans ces moments là c'est
particulièrement envie de revenir auprès
de ceux qui que je connais et me
connaissent pour savoir ce qu'ils
pensent
comment ils comprennent cette double
parole gens qui comprennent cette
journée de dimanche pour les chômeurs a
été marquée par quelques occupations
sauvages pas de mouvements coordonnés
mais ici à cherbourg des sans emploi
occupent toujours les locaux de la
chambre de commerce même chose à
strasbourg et dans le pas de calais
arras depuis hier les chômeurs sont
installés dans un bâtiment géré par la
mairie vincent nguyen pas plus que
l'appétit ils n'ont perdu l'espoir
déloger de l'antenne assedic il occupait
cette cinquantaine de chômeurs vit
depuis deux jours et deux nuits dans la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
cherbourg le fait simplement pour se
retrouver simplement dette sociale fait
ça permet que on ne perd pas le moral on
retrouve de lesparre et puis on s'en
sort mieux remonter il explique à qui
veut entendre la précarité de leur
situation
ça sent francs par mois et une fois que
tout est payé ne reste que deux enfants
par jour se nomme faire
74 les couches r&d centimes vers un
revenu de 2002 120 francs par mois
je touche et 2000 francs c'est dire
enfin partir de ce mois ci dix neuf ans
je sais pas comment je vais faire
ces doléances ont même ému le président
de la chambre de commerce qui ce matin a
même apporté les croissants aux chômeurs
en colère nous soulage est une plaie en
france on a beaucoup de mal à créer de
l'activité économique et que je plains
beaucoup fait genre like qu' on essaie
de faire tout ce qu'on peut pour créer
de l'activité créer de l'emploi mais que
c'est pas facile à arras c'est la maison
des sociétés que les chômeurs ont
investi hier au total cinq sites en
france reste occupé aujourd'hui la
fatigue se fait ressentir chez les
militants mais on attend un nouveau pic
de mobilisation mardi et le président
dassier chômage prévoit même de
nouvelles occupations de locaux
la classe politique continue de réagir à
la fois aux évacuations des assedic mais
aussi aux mesures annoncées par lionel
jospin edouard balladur tout à l'heure
au grand jury rtl et dominique voynet
sur un repas nous les écoutes dans today
ce que je constate aujourd'hui c'est que
c'est vrai nous ne sommes plus dans la
situation qui avait permis peut-être de
considérer ses occupations comme
légitime pourquoi dont vous avez fait
que l'occupation
l'occupation est un geste grave
un geste radical un geste qu'on pose
quand on est acculé
quand on veut forcer le dialogue
aujourd'hui le dialogue est rétabli il
est restaurée et les chômeurs sont reçus
dans les ministères et dans les
préfectures
premier point fallait il faire évacuer
les locaux des assedic la réponse est
oui on ne pouvait pas accepter que cela
dure trop longtemps
deuxième point est ce que le milliard
données résout le problème c'est
absolument dérisoire compte tenu de
l'objectif dérisoire mais détresse de
langue du ray touche aujourd'hui plus
d'un million de chômeurs qui depuis des
années n'arrive plus à trouver leur
place sur le marché de l'emploi
portrait près de strasbourg d'un couple
toutes deux au chômage depuis quatre ans
la débrouille et l'énergique s'en sortir
soutenus ces dernières semaines par le
mouvement des chômeurs reportage
jérôme soûlard sylvain gauthier
un dimanche ordinaire dans la famille
france reb depuis quatre ans michel
patricia et leurs trois enfants vivent
le chômage et la précarité au quotidien
sans jamais pourtant avoir cédé au
désespoir
je suis toujours actif c'est vrai que
c'est pas évident de de travailler
uniquement pour des petits coups de main
parce que le monde
les rentrées d'argent ne se font pas
mais en ce moment il n'y a pas grand
chose avec 44 ans j'ai 44 ans mais est
considéré comme gay considérer disons
que tu es considéré comme un lieu à
l'anpe alors depuis trois ans
michel s'activent dans l'intérim après
trois semaines sans contrat il
recommence à travailler demain 15 jours
de salaire qui permettent aujourd'hui à
patricia de servir de la viande à ses
enfants
j'avais déjà dit moi que je m'en sortais
avec 2000 2500 pour moi bon on mangeait
tous les jours mais bon il y avait
beaucoup de rythme et beaucoup de
des pâtes les pommes de terre ça leur
donne un petit peu de fierté un petit
peu de baume au coeur de voir ces autres
chômeurs qui se mobilisent pour beaucoup
même parce que bon c'est vrai qu'il nous
dit qu'il fallait qu'il se passe quelque
chose il fallait quand même qu'on montre
que même en étant sans emploi
on a le droit de vivre normalement comme
n'importe quel autre citoyen ce qui ne
se faisait pas ces derniers temps parce
que bon on va lier quand même disons
certaines certaine façon de refuser les
gens qu'elle est vraiment désagréable un
peu de considération retrouvé et un vrai
bonheur pour la famille grâce à ce petit
carré de jardin 700 francs par an qui
joint l'utile à l'agréable des légumes
et des vacances pour pas cher la douleur
des parents de la petite marion disparu
agen en novembre 96 s'ajoute maintenant
des tentatives d'escroqueries des
personnes peu scrupuleuses cherche à
faire de l'argent avec des informations
fantaisistes ce week-end un homme se
présentant comme un détective privé a
été interpellé david béziers rive du
mail la veille de noël michel wago le
père de marion reçoit un coup de
téléphone un détective privé affirme
avoir retrouvé l'enfant à l'étranger
mais exige une grosse somme pour la
ramener dans sa famille on vit déjà un
calvaire depuis 14 mois c'était le
deuxième noël sans marion on a fait
confiance à cet individu bon rapidement
les enquêteurs alertés en découvert ont
tout de suite mis l'accent sur une
affaire d'escroquerie
la cellule de recherche chargé
spécialement de marion prend le
détective en filature lors de son
passage vendredi dernier il est
interpellé à voiron près de grenoble
il aurait avoué mais la gendarmerie se
refuse à toute communication sur la
sphère
c'est la dixième fois qu'on réclame de
l'argent à michel ragon mais difficile
de déceler les escroqueries
lorsque l'on guette le moindre espoir à
retrouver de l'intérêt de faire un film
qui retrace le parcours qu'elle est
susceptible d'avoir fait d'intégrer son
image et d'animer son image telle
qu'elle est dans la réalité et de la
diffuser certains fantasment sur
puisqu'il donne certaines précisions sur
la disparition de l'enfant sur ce
qu'elle est devenue
howell vie et puis je pense qu'il ya des
intérêts du cesi ski qui veulent
absolument qu'on parle d'eux et puis il
ya ceux qui veulent sa part jean michel
waggon portera plainte à chaque
tentative d'escroquerie sur son espoir
mais il espère toujours un site internet
vient d'être consacré à marion à
l'entrée dû tunnel sous la manche saisie
record 160 kilos de cocaïne dissimulés
dans les roues d'une voiture il s'agit
de l'une des plus importantes prises
jamais effectuées par les douaniers
britanniques mathieu chez l' avantage du
4 4
offrir une motricité sans pareil autre
atout de ce véhicule pour les
stupéfiants de largeur ou capable
d'abriter de la cocaïne environ 160 kg
ont en effet été découverts par les
douaniers britanniques cachées dans les
pneus de ce véhicule alors que les
passagers s'apprêtaient à passer en
grande bretagne via le tunnel sous la
manche
c'est une merveilleuse idée pour
transporter de la drogue on n'aurait
jamais pensé aller chercher là
d'habitude on fouille à l'intérieur des
véhicules mais on n'aurait jamais
imaginé que des trafiquants puissent
rouler avec 40 kilos de cocaïne dans
chaque roue les deux trafiquants ont été
appréhendés par des anglais
sur le sol français car selon un accord
international chaque pays peut contrôler
des deux côtés de la manche
et il ya de quoi faire l'eurotunnel est
devenue le lieu d'intenses trafic
début décembre les douaniers français
avaient eux aussi été à l'honneur grâce
à un scanner il avait démasqué un camion
anglais chargés d'héroïne pour une
valeur de 120 millions de francs
la drogue était cette fois là cachées
dans du papier toilette de la créativité
qui oblige les douaniers à faire preuve
d'imagination pour découvrir les
dernières cachette à la mode des
stupéfiants antibes un cambriolage
tourne au drame trois hommes armés et
cagoulés embusqués dans une propriété
ont contraint les pouces d'un chirurgien
à rentrer à l'intérieur de la maison le
docteur est sorti armé s'en est suivie
une fusillade
yasmina farber et diane richard soir à
23h30 ce quartier résidentiel d'antibes
est bien calme l'api dans l'ombre dans
le jardin de la villa belvédère sur le
chemin de vallauris trois hommes
attendent que madame chaleil sortent de
la maison pour promener son chien
ensuite tout s'accélère quinze coups de
feu des appels au secours et des voisins
qui arrivent sur les lieux
la voisine nous a ouvert et
objectivement constaté
qu'il y avait une intrusion de 2,3 trois
malfaiteurs cagoulés armés qui
semble-t-il est attendue qu'elle ouvre
ses portes pour pour bousculer la
traînée par terre l'a traînée vers le
premier son mari s'était rabattu aux
comptes sont en bois semblablement et
puis il ya eu cet échange de coups de
feu qui s'est traduit par parlement de
du voisin et d'un des matches le docteur
chaleil chirurgien la retraite très
connu à antibes a probablement été
victime d'un guet-apens penser que ce
sont des gens qui nous attend dès qu'ils
ont une excellente habitués ne sait pas
qu'il connaissait mais ils avaient
sûrement faire attention à ce qu'on n'a
pas ce pas les enfants dans leur jardin
après avoir escaladé la grille le
malfaiteur abattu par le chirurgien a
été identifié cet homme de 35 ans
d'origine algérienne résidait à
vallauris la police judiciaire de nice
recherche ses deux complices qui ont
réussi à prendre la fuite après la
fusillade
120 skieurs ont été bloqués cet après
midi sur un télésiège en panne de la
station des orres les crs de montagne
les gendarmes ont été obligés de
mobiliser trois hélicoptères pour les
secours et les citoyens d'une petite
commune près de montpellier décide de
prendre en main leur environnement un
référendum s'est tenue aujourd'hui pour
savoir s'il y aura dans l'avenir un
centre de tri et de recyclage des
déchets car inkomazi parce qu'elles
pensent dans la salle des fêtes du petit
village de valergues rennes aujourd'hui
l'agitation des grands jours de
consultations nationales
vous lisez qui aujourd'hui ne l'ont
c'est un référendum sa porte sur quoi
sur oui ou non un centre de retraitement
de déchets mâchefers et c'est un projet
encombrants qui s'inscrit dans un vaste
programme celui du traitement des
ordures ménagères
c'est le village voisin accueillera
l'incinérateur il reste à trouver un
site pour les déchets et les résidus
toxiques sont les 82 communes concernées
celles valergues s'est portée candidate
le rôle de mère et de développer le
tissu économique de sa copine développer
le tissu économique de sa commune pour
deux raisons créer des emplois d'une
part d'autre part générer de la taxe
professionnelle mais à valergues comme
ailleurs stocker les déchets fait peur
et pourtant le temps presse
selon la loi déchets de 1992 les
décharges traditionnels comme celle ci
aux portes de montpellier auront disparu
en 2002 quatre ans de travail de titan
le tout aux frais des collectivités que
l'état incite à trier et recycler plutôt
qu'à tout incinérés mais ici on a
préféré parer au plus pressé
les communes ont confié pour 25 ans
l'incinération de leurs ordures
ménagères à la lyonnaise des eaux le
temps de mieux organiser le tri des
déchets il ne pourra donc commencer dès
l'été l'été 98 avec le tri existant
aujourd'hui qui est un prix de l'ordre
de 20 % de déchets ménagers pour les
pros les syndicats les artisans
suffisant puisque l'objectif du plan
départemental et 2 45% à 10 ans dont
nous avons encore un certain nombre
d'années pour arriver aux objectifs du
plan départemental en attendant plus de
80% des déchets ménagers seront
incinérées plastiques métaux tout
partira en fumée
autant de dioxine qui inquiète les
opposants mais si le recyclage est fait
correctement les déchets ultimes ne sont
pas que le haut il faut savoir qu'un
incinérateur sera toujours plus beaucoup
plus cher et beaucoup plus polluant que
même les plus mauvaise des charges qui
existe actuellement et qui sont tant
décrié sur la france les opposants ont
demandé au tribunal administratif
l'arrêt des travaux de l'incinérateur
s'il échoue 4000 tonnes de déchets
seront incinérées chaque année en pleine
campagne à 10 km de montpellier
en alsace deux écoles ont été la cible
de la violence urbaine deux explosions
criminelles ont eu lieu samedi soir
l'une dans la banlieue de strasbourg
l'autre à mulhouse un engin explosif un
extincteur rempli de produits détonants
a soufflé les vitres des salles de
l'école primaire
un peu plus tard à mulhouse une
explosion a fait quelques dégâts dans le
quartier des coteaux et c'est mardi
prochain que jacques chirac recevra 12
maire pour évoquer les violences
urbaines ne seront présents des élus
locaux de toute sensibilité avec pour
point commun la gestion de quartiers
sensibles dans des villes moyennes je
vous propose ce portrait croisé du maire
communiste de vénissieux et du maire rpr
de dammarie-les-lys reportage philippe
visseyrias olivier galzi s'en fait pas
ici ou en asie l'incompréhension d'un
maire au coeur de la cité le tout
nouveau centre culturel a été saccagé 2
2 millions nous n'avons même pas eu ce
qu'en dit new york les faits remontent
au mois de décembre un jeune du quartier
tombent sous les balles de la police
lors d'une course-poursuite c'est
l'étincelle la cité du lys jusqu'ici un
quartier tranquille s'enflamme et fera
la une de l'actualité
le petit lieu de convivialité pour le
holiday du vivre ensemble
andré gerin est fier de montrer l'effort
de rénovation du quartier des minguettes
il faut dire que le maire communiste de
vénissieux est déjà un vétéran dans la
lutte contre la violence urbaine étaient
80 les jeunes se révoltent aux
minguettes les voitures brûlent la
france découvre effaré le malaise des
banlieues
dix sept ans plus tard on a abattu 14
tours on a mis en place tout un ensemble
de structures sociales mais la
délinquance est toujours là et les gens
ont peur au wydad racontaient qu'ils ont
la peur tous les jours or seront se fait
cracher à la figure
on peut rentrer à dammarie les lys
on n'était pas habitué à la violence
alors on s'interroge pourquoi en est on
arrivé là
alors ça va ouais ça se calme un petit
peu mal minuit et les employés d'au
moins palau me ravit à l'eau par an
quand ils vont faire des bisous pas
l'avis de vos parents problème façon
quand même leurs enfants c'est pas moi
qui les ai faits abbas à niveau ouais
donc il faut que je prenne nos
responsabilités enfants visite au centre
commercial au coeur des minguettes
devant l'augmentation de la délinquance
la mairie a recruté quatre agents
municipaux supplémentaires arrivent et
cinq heures du soir
il ya plus qu il y en a et galerie
accueille des jeunes avec des couteaux
on voit que ça les clients dont ce fut
hier dans la galerie
bonjour avec les jeunes du quartier le
contact est plus difficile ici le
chômage touche 35 % des actifs ils vont
à vancouver laissant la réponse est
claire il n'a pas réponse à tout il
mobilise au lieu de mobiliser plus de
flics dans les cartes et de mobiliser
plus de nous on n'a pas tout
même si pour mais aussi pour que l'état
y passe plus voilà donc là c'est la
fameuse passerelle du rhône laquelle il
ya quelques temps l'individu a balancé
une plaque d'égout en fonte depuis de 20
kg sur le veto de police qui
patrouillaient qu'est ce que vous allez
dire à jacques chirac
je veux dire c'est qu'il est grand temps
de restaurer l'autorité de l'état dans
les cités mayas générale en france se
trouvait temps c'est que la justice fait
son travail avec efficacité
il faut réfléchir autour des valeurs
morales culturelles et éthiques
et surtout le fait que les institutions
les entreprises la cité la famille ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui l'incivilité a
été a touché toute la société
et c'est cette question de fond je
voudrais traité auprès du présent un
public tant que nous n'arriverons pas à
trouver une solution pour non pas punir
mais pour qu'il y ait une menace
financière et par rapport à l'attitude
de certains parents nous n'arriverons
pas je n'ai pas de solution miracle
j'ai des idées j'ai une façon de voir la
société française mais je crois que le
renouveau passera par ce sursaut civique
et citoyen mêlez vous de ses tenues ou
concert mardi le rpr jean claude mignon
et le communiste andré gerin
rencontreront le président de la
république si leurs solutions diffèrent
leur objectif est le même
voir la question des banlieues devenir
une priorité nationale la crise
financière et banquière en indonésie
risque de paralysie
l'économie entière du pays
l'effondrement la semaine dernière de la
monnaie provoque la panique de la
population qui s'est mise à dévaliser
les magasins est désormais le chaos
économique est touche les politiques
jean paul chapelle nourriture de base
pour 200 millions d'indonésiens le riz
est désormais rationnés nous sommes sur
le principal marché de jakarta la foule
se presse pour faire des stocks
craignant une flambée des prix craignant
surtout la pénurie je fais la queue
depuis 5 heures du matin pour être sûr
de pouvoir acheter du riz
pour tenter de rassurer la population
ces images sont diffusées à la
télévision indonésienne sur le port de
jakarta on y voit la précieuse
nourriture importés de thaïlande ou du
vietnam par sac de 50 kg résultat un
mythe s'effondre celui de
l'autosuffisance alimentaire dans un
pays qui a mis trente ans à oublier les
familles du coup la crise économique
devient politique
figure emblématique de l'opposition
madame megawati réclame aujourd'hui la
démission du président soir peut prendre
deux ans ça suffit
le plongeon tragique de notre monette
démontre la perte de confiance du peuple
dans le gouvernement actuel
une scène à peine croyable dans ce pays
réputé pour sa soumission à l'autorité
et son respect pour le président cet
éclat constitue même un délit criminel
aux termes de la loi indonésienne à
belfast c'est le neveu de gerry adams
leader du sinn féin qui a été assassiné
la nuit dernière par une milice
protestante opposés au processus de paix
cette milice a revendiqué l'attentât en
déclarant que c'était une réponse
directe au meurtre de leur chef tué fin
décembre dans une prison de haute
sécurité le cycle de la violence des
représailles ne devrait pas remettre en
question les négociations en cours gerry
adams particulièrement affecté accuse
ceux qui résistent au changement
le pape jean paul 2 victime d'un léger
retour 10 mans ce matin juste avant de
célébrer la messe au vatican
c'est alors qu'il entrait dans la
chapelle sixtine le saint-père a
ressenti un malaise qui s'est rapidement
dissipée
le pape a célébré la messe est baptisé
plusieurs enfants pas d'inquiétude donc
au vatican on parle de fatigue et rien
ne devrait remettre en question le
voyage à cuba de jean paul ii du 21 au
26 janvier prochain en algérie à raïs au
sud de la capitale les massacres d'août
dernier qui ont fait plus de 200 morts
laisse des traces indescriptible dans
les mémoires quatre mois après la vie
tente de se réorganiser sous la
protection 2000
ce villageoise reportage demande où
angie recommandé par bernard lebrun les
voitures blindées de l'armée entre dans
la ville les habitants ne détourne même
plus la tête c'est patrouilles sont
désormais régulière mais fait nouveau il
y a désormais une milice villageoise à
sidi raïs rien de tout cela il ya quatre
mois maintenant vous êtes là est bien
claire différence
le silence un calme pesant dans les rues
reflet du malaise et du traumatisme des
habitants
la vie continue à raïs fébrilement avec
son lot de difficultés économiques en
dehors de l'agriculture il n'y a pas de
travail ici et donc pas d'argent
le boulanger comme petit épicier et pas
débordés par les clients après le
massacre du 29 août dernier des
psychologues venus d'alger ont passé un
mois ici surtout avec les enfants
détruit mais partiellement incendiée par
les agresseurs le collège raïs est
désormais fermée il y a les destructions
d'immeubles palpable concrète ce puis il
ya les des gaz invisible dans les
cerveaux ceux provoqués par la douleur
et la terreur
ce jour là il était environ 20 ou 30
beaucoup en tout les carter de ma
famille ils ont égorgé 17 personnes dans
trois de mes enfants
les habitants de raïs nous même pas le
goût ni les moyens d'effacer les traces
du massacre dans la plaine de la mitidja
mais village martyr pleurent leurs morts
dans le silence la dignité pour le
centenaire du fameux j'accuse d'emile
zola publié à la une du journal l'aurore
il est un siècle différents hommages
dont celui rendu cet après midi à la
bibliothèque nationale
une exposition réunissant texte et
objets ayant notamment appartenu à
l'auteur a été inaugurée par le ministre
de la culture catherine trautmann et
alain richard ministre de la défense
la vérité est en marche publié à trois
cent mille exemplaires le texte d'emile
zola dans les formules sont passés à la
postérité a fait basculer la france
emile zola avec son j'accuse ouvrait la
voie à nouveau pouvoir celui des médias
geneviève moll j'accuse le
lieutenant-colonel du pâtis deux clament
avoir été l'ouvrier diabolique de
l'erreur judiciaire
le général messier de s'être rendue
complice tout au moins par faiblesse
d'esprit d'une des plus grande dignité
du siècle et mise là écrit cette lettre
ouverte au président de la république
des leaks fort pour raconter tout ce
qu'il sait de l' affaire dreyfus et
dénoncer les coupables qui ont envoyé un
innocent en prison
comment en est-il arrivé là en 1894 le
capitaine alfred dreyfus accusés
d'espionnage au profit de l'allemagne
est jugée à huit clos condamné à la
dégradation et à la relégation au bagne
de cayenne
bien qu'il hurle son innocence deux ans
plus tard le véritable coupable est
démasqué c'est un autre officier le
commando était razzi mais la haine
antisémite de l'état majeur et la
solidarité de la caste militaire couvre
esterhazy cela ne le supporte pas il
écrit j'accuse parce qu'ils croient que
il faut qu'un acte supplémentaire soit
réalisé qu'une étape soit franchie et
que il a le droit lui de le faire ou non
de sa conscience littéraire au nom de la
conscience qu'il a d'être à cette époque
le plus grand écrivain de la littérature
française qu'est ce que cherchent ceux
là il veut être jugé être jugé pour
diffamation à ceux comme ça il y aura un
véritable procès puisque le procès de
dreyfus a été un procès occulter puisque
le procès d'esterhazy a été un procès
occulté il y aura cette fois ci un
véritable procès où l'on pourra citer
tous les témoins et faire la preuve de
l'innocence de dreyfus ce moment c'est
lui qui en supportera les conséquences
ou
le jeudi 13 janvier 1898 dans une eau
glaciale
trois cent mille exemplaires de l'aurore
sont vendu à la criée avec ce titre qui
barre les six colonnes de la hune
l'accusent par emile zola
un mois plus tard comme il le désirait
vue-là est jugé pour diffamation en cour
d'assises
mais deux ans témoin qui touche de près
ou de loin la sphère dreyfus sont
entendus la vérité est enfin en marche
bien que l'écrivain soit condamné la
presse prend alors la place qu'elle aura
au 20e siècle
elle fait l'opinion pour au contrôle à
elle est libérale ou antisémite elle
montre cette france coupée en deux
contre laquelle zola se bat mais
j'accuse marque surtout la naissance
d'une attitude nouvelle l'engagement des
intellectuels
l'engagement collectif va naître du
j'accuse
l'engagement collectif qui va se
perpétuer et oui ou à la fin du 19e et
tout au long du xxème siècle tous les
manifeste signé par tous les
intellectuels pour servir la vérité la
justice mais ce qui est remarquable
c'est que ceci est née d'un engagement
solitaire l'engagement de zola c'est
l'engagement d'un écrivain solitaire et
qui écrira ensuite d'ailleurs en termes
très émouvant maintenant que j'ai rempli
ma tâche je retourne à mes livres mais
il n'arrivera pas le dernier
la vérité il meurt le 29 septembre 1902
emile zola à tout au long de sa carrière
par la société de son temps est décrit
en journalistes qu'ils étaient les
souffrances de l'époque
cent ans après la vie dans les
bidonvilles et le problème de
l'intégration réussie aurait pu inspirer
cela je vous propose avec la sortie
mercredi prochain du gone du chaâba une
émouvante comédie sur l'intégration
agon s'est en argot lyonnais un gamin
est précisément le film retrace le
parcours d'un enfant né dans un
bidonville français dans les années 60
stefanou mans frédéric basket comme un
appel au marché
je n'ai pas pu tant son enfance
omar l'a passée dans un bidonville comme
il en existait plusieurs aux portes de
paris lyon marseille dans les années 60
chronique chaleureuse d'une vie
provisoire le bidonville avait même un
nom les enfants d'aujourd'hui découvre
au cinéma ce passé oublié et tes parents
ils sont pas nocives on ne leur a jamais
demandé pourquoi ils sont venus comment
ça s'est passé de paris tous avec tes
parents
pourquoi
franchement leur histoire qu'est ce
qu'on fait ici
le gisement est le titre le déguisement
vous allez à la ligne ce joli film est
aussi l'histoire vraie d'une intégration
réussie grâce à l'école aux instituteurs
et à la langue française d'un vieux
chapeau chapo le petit homard
c'est lui azouz begag chercheur au cnrs
qui a raconté son enfance
d'abord mon père on me montre en semaine
de maçon they moi j'ai que ça pour
travailler je suis en main d'oeuvre mais
disait toi pour réussir dans la vie il
faut utiliser ça aussi c'est l'école qui
donne ça l'intelligence la culture et
m'a dit à l'école je vis un premier de
la classe devant les français ça ça me
ferait plaisir travailler lire écrire et
que j'aimerai marc dépressif quand ce
sera trop dur je terminerais levier je
me mettrai à courir vers les étoiles
ce premier film de christophe ruggia
adopte le point de vue des enfants comme
une guerre des boutons qui nous
parlerait d'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui à méribel s'est déroulée la
finale du trophée de savoie une des plus
grandes courses de vitesse d'attelage de
chiens de traîneaux benoît gallerey
thierry simonet a lâché allait se battre
comme avec bord qui valent à vannes oc
sur le circuit de l'airé du retail s'est
fait un nom des raids et des courses de
chiens de traîneaux
elle a fait son métier avant chaque
épreuve elle compose son attelage de
chiens selon un ordre bien établi son
léché qui sont rapides qui donne la
cadence et touristes rêvant aux ordres
et puis assistent régulièrement des
chiens étions vraiment la pêche derrière
la déchetterie puissant qui donne
vraiment le ratage
il y assure cette course les meilleurs
conducteurs de traîneaux d'europe
on les appelle les mushers une course
par catégories en fonction de
l'importance de l'attelage des chiens
nordiques pour la plupart même si la
tendance est à l'introduction de race de
sprinteurs comme le lévrier
on a des petits mots chacun dans les 6m
pour le relancer sur la piste du genre
ok allez demain peuvent aller bébé voilà
ils ressentent pas ça de façon très bien
et puis bon dès qu'ils ont perçus il
relance le même c'est bien gore qui
donne à une mort qui aujourd'hui la
distance à parcourir battait de 12 km
avec un fort dénivelé
les meilleurs ont mis moins de 25
minutes
et puis il ya les autres les débutants
comme loris à peine 8 ans et déjà sur un
traîneau
donner des ordres aux chiens le plaisir
de glisser le paie et le plaisir de
compétition plus jeunes mais aussi plus
léger loris n'est pas arrivé le dernier
aujourd'hui loin de là et pour cela ces
chiens ont pété tendrement remercier
tennis en australie avec la victoire
d'un petit prodige lettonie où est âgé
de 16 ans a remporté le tournoi
d'adélaïde alors qu ils étaient 500 50e
au classement mondial il a battu agassi
ancien numéro un mondial et sa carrière
semblera peut-être à celle de michael
chang vainqueur à san francisco en 88 à
l'âge lui de 16 ans le tirage au sort
des huitièmes de finale de la coupe de
la ligue de football a eu lieu cet après
midi à noter la rencontre choc psg
montpellier seul match qui opposera deux
clubs de première division
les rencontres seront retransmises les
31 janvier et 1er février sur france
télévisions actualité très riche en
cinéma puisque mercredi prochain sortie
de lolita tiré du roman de vladimir
nabokov un film sulfureux sur les amours
d'un professeur et d'une a fait de 14
ans interprété par jeremy hunt et la
toute jeune dominique semaine pascale
deschamps
philippe deslandes
je
en adaptant une nouvelle fois quarante
ans après le lolita de vladimir nabokov
adrian lyne ne se doutait pas des
difficultés qu'il attendait comme le
livre rejetée par les éditeurs
américains en 1954 avant d'être un
succès mondial
son fils mais depuis un an refusée par
les principaux distributeurs outre
atlantique
lolita sent le soufre à nos mômes à ce
film ne parle pas de quelqu'un qui viole
assassiné en terre une enfant de 6 ans
on parle d'un homme qui tombe amoureux
d'une adolescente de 14 ans il prend
soin d'elle elle s'occupe d'elle c'est
très différent
oui c'est ce criminel oui c'est
contraire à la loi
oui c'est quoi le smad mais c'est pareil
pour le meur et pourtant voit tous les
jours des films qui en sont pleins
raconté à la première personne
lolita est l'histoire d'une descente aux
enfers celle d'un homme qui va jusqu'au
bout de sa passion
dutil détruire sa vie le professeur
possèdera l'objet de son désir
l'entraînera dans un voyage sans retour
il n'y aura ni bonheur ni sérénité au
bout du chemin simplement l'idée qu'à
jouer avec ses fantasmes
l'homme perd son âme finalement tout
cela est très moral et donc le cinéma
devrait nous permettre comme cela a
toujours été le cas dans l'intimité
d'une salle obscure et en respectant les
lois bien sûr de voir des histoires qui
parfois nous effraie nous étonne nous
déconcerte
mais nous font un peu mieux comprendre
la nature humaine
pas de chance pour adrian line la sortie
de lolita tombe un de ces moments où une
société proclame que ce sont les films
et les livres qui suscitent les excès
alors qu'ils n'en sont que le reflet
ainsi se termine ce journal je vous en
rappelle les principaux titres
les chômeurs ne désarme pas après
l'évacuation des assedic d'autres
occupations à metz à guingamp à lyon à
nantes les neiges aux paliers justifie
sa politique de fermeté 160 kilos de
cocaïne répartis dans les quatre roues
d'une voiture la plus grosse saisie de
drogue à l'entrée dû tunnel sous la
manche dans un instant la météo laurent
romejko 20h50 une lueur dans la nuit
avec michael douglas et mélanie griffith
de ma 7h50 dans les 4 vérités françaises
abordent recevra alain richard ministre
de la défense demain soir à 20h vous
retrouverez daniel bilalian je vous
remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2
non